bonjour à tous vous allez pouvoir suivre
dans un instant les premières auditions
de la mission commune d'information sur
la réalité de l'impact sur l'emploi des
exonérations de cotisation social
accordé aux entreprises alors cette
mission d'information a été créée ici au
Sénat à l'initiative du groupe
communiste l'objectif en clair est de
réfléchir aux contreparties accordés aux
entreprises pour le fameux pacte de
responsabilité voilà nous on se retrouve
tout de suite après maises mes chers
collègues madame monsieur nous nous
ouvrons donc aujourd'hui nos travaux
donc sur cette mission commune
d'information relative à la réalité de
l'impact sur l'emploi des exonérations
de cotisation social accordé aux
entreprises
euh nous avons choisi donc de débuter
par deux auditions on va dire
introductives et nous avons demandé donc
à Madame enen Paris et à Monsieur Pierre
cahuk donc du Conseil d'analyse
économique de venir nous exposer le le
raisonnement économique sur lequel
repose la la politique d'exonération des
cotisations sociales et donc je
souhaitais tout d'abord les remercier
d'avoir accepté notre inv
invitation je vous rappelle que le
Conseil d'analyse économique est placé
auprès du premier ministre qui est
composé d'économistes universitaires et
de chercheurs et qu'il réaliseent donc
des analyses économiques indépendantes
qui sont rendues
publiques donc spécialiste du marché du
travail Monsieur Pierre cahuk est
l'auteur de de nombreux ouvrages sur les
travaux sur le sujet qui nous
occupe nous lui avons demandé de bien
vouloir rappeler dans un premier temps
les fondements économiques des
politiques d'allègement de cotisation et
de préciser les indicateurs et les
outils de l'évaluation de cette
politique quant à ses effets sur
l'emploi puis de nous livrer le le fruit
de ses travaux sur le sujet avec les les
annonces qui ont été faites par le
Président de la République sur le pacte
de responsabilité dont les
contours devrait être précisé
prochainement mais dont on a eu quelques
quelques quelques éléments lors de de sa
dernière intervention euh bon il semble
que les allègements de cotisation
devraient se poursuivre et sacentuer dès
lors un débat c'est ouvert que je
résumerai rapidement de la façon
suivante faut-il concentrer des
allègements des cotisations sur les
bases salairire ou faut-il mener une
politique plus générale de renforcement
de la compétitivité de nos entreprises
qui allie à action sur le coût du
travail et politique
fiscale bon je pense que nous ne
manquerons pas de vous interroger
là-dessus mais peut-être pourriez-vous
commencer par une introduction
sur sur ces éléments et ensuite donc je
donnerai la parole à Madame la
rapporteur donc Madame Michelle de
Messine pour les premières questions en
sachant que cette mission a été proposé
par le groupe CRC et ensuite nous
passerons aux questions de nos collègues
je vous remercie de de bien vouloir
intervenir je vais passer la la parole
tout d'abord merci pour cette
introduction à Hélène Paris qui est
secrétaire général du CAE et qui va
donner quelques mots d'introduction
générale sur le sujet
oui bonjour à tous bon en effet je je
vais faire une petite introduction et
pour rappeler les les les le
raisonnement économique qui est à la
base des des dispositifs d'exonération
d'allègement des des cotisations
sociales et je passerai la parole bien
sûr assez rapidement à Pierre Cahu qui
est un grand spécialiste de cette
question et dont on on est ravi qu'il
soit membre du Conseil d'analyse
économique et qui nous éclaire sur ces
questions
euh alors est-ce que ça marche comme ça
oui voilà donc juste un petit rappel des
la motivation initiale he pour qui a
conduit à
alléger à mettre en place des
allégements généraux de cotisation
sociale donc ça vous le savez tous hein
donc c'est ces réflexions ont débuté au
début des années 90
euh sur la base d'un d'un double constat
d'une part la déterrioration
déterrioration de la situation du marché
du travail et en particulier pour les
personnes les moins qualifiées euh donc
un développement de de chômage important
et une vraie situation de de sous-emploi
et euh d'autre part le constat de la
réduction de l'écart entre le coût du
travail au niveau du SMIC et celui euh
au niveau du salaire moyen euh donc je
peux citer par exemple le rapport
Charpin en 1992 euh qui
euh faisait le constat qu'il n'y avait
pas enfin la France se trouvait pas
spécifiquement handicapée à l'époque euh
au niveau du du du coût du travail du
coût du travail moyen euh mais que il y
avait un une réduction de de l'écart
très fort au entre le salaire minimum et
ce ce niveau de salaire moyen et que euh
parallèlement donc le développement de
du du chômage des des personnes les
moins qualifiés n'était pas ne
s'ajustait pas au regard de l'évolution
de leur productivité et ce qui posait un
un vrai problème donc sur la situation
du marché du travail euh d'autant que
l'évolution comment dire le billet
technologique allait dans le sens d'une
demande croissante en en direction
d'emploi plus qualifié et donc pour
résumer une structure du cûpt du travail
qui devenait de plus en plus défavorable
au aux aux personnes peu qualifiées et
c'est ce qui donc a motivé c'était la
première motivation pour euh trouver des
moyens d'alléger euh le coût du travail
via euh ces allègements de cotisation
sociale euh oui là je vois que c'est un
peu petit en projection donc mais ça
vous vous les connaissez bien c'est un
rappel des dispositifs qui ont été mis
en place donc depuis le début des années
90 enfin depuis 93 hein donc dans un
premier temps euh ce qu'on a appelé la
phase offensive où donc il s'agissait
bien de réduire le coût du travail au
voisinage du SMIC et donc on avait un
dispositif qui était
ciblé avec un seuil de sortie autour de
1,2 1,3 SMIC c'est ce qu'on a appelé les
exonérations baladure puis Jup euh et
puis donc jusqu'en 1998 et ensuite on
est passé à une deuxième grande phase
enfin en deux parties ce qu'on appelait
une phase plus défensive où là il y
avait des motivations qui se sont
comment dire diversifié euh donc tout
d'abord la période
19982002 où donc là le champ des
allègements était étendu aux entreprises
qui réduisaient leur temps de travail et
donc là il s'agissait de compenser
l'impact de la réduction du temps de
travail sur le coût du travail avec un
un CC de sortie qui a été un peu déplacé
vers le haut hein puisque donc le seil
de sortie de ce dispositif qu'on appelle
exénération au BRI euh et ceci situe se
situait entre 1,6 et 1,7 SMIC et puis
une 3ème étape si je puux dire en les
années 2003 200005 c'est les
exonérations Fillon où donc là c'est une
espèce de poursuite de phase défensive
dans ces allègement de cotisation
sociale pour neutraliser l'impact de la
convergence vers le haut du
SMIC donc si si on résume si on fait
masse de tous ces dispositifs
d'alléigement de cotisation sociale en
2007 avec une montée en charge accomplie
on se retrouve avec une réduction de 26
points
euh de cotisation social au niveau du
SMIC euh pour les entreprises de plus 20
salariés avec un seuil de sortie à
1,6 Smic
euh c'est c'est ces masses d'allègement
de cotisation sociale représente un
engagement budgétaire important hein
puisque c'est c'est un peu plus de 20
milliards d'euros et donc un point de
PIB
euh plus récemment encore donc on a un
niveau dispositif qui cette fois
s'pparente pas enfin un petit peu
différent des exénérations de cotisation
sociale puisque c'est donc le crédit
d'impôt compétitivité et emploi le cice
qui a été donc instauré en 2013 et qui a
un ciblage un peu différent he puisque
le seil de sortie est à 2,5 SMIC et qui
lui-même en monté en charge à l'horizon
de l'année prochaine représente un
engagement budgétaire enfin une dépense
fiscale de 20 milliards d'euros donc un
point de PIB
également alors voilà un petit graphique
pour illustrer alors ça ne n'intègre pas
le CIC parce que on s'arrête en 2009 euh
mais donc vous voyez du coup de manière
assez frappante l'effet des allègements
de cotisation sociale en représentant
l'évolution du coût du travail relatif
euh au niveau du SMIC euh donc en fait
c'est le rapport entre le le SMIC et le
salaire
médian donc d'une part on s'intéresse au
salaire net et d'autre part au cût du
travail euh donc jusque en au début des
années 90 et ben en fait les deux
courbes étaient parfaitement
coïncidentes enfin donc en fait elles
évoluaient de la même façon et à partir
de la mise en place de cette politique
d'allègement cotisation sociale et bien
le coût du
travail a évolué beaucoup moins vite au
niveau du SMIC enfin en tout cas oui au
niveau du SMIC par rapport au au au coût
du travail au salaire médian en revanche
au niveau des salaires nets on ne voit
pas du tout la même la même évolution
donc ça montre un peu l'ampleur disons
de enfin l'action de ces dispositifs et
l'effet massif des allègements de
cotisation sociale à ce à cet
endroit dans dans le raisonnement
économique mais si je l'ai un tout petit
peu évoqué euh tout à l'heure donc B
l'objectif macroéconomique principal he
comme je l'ai dit au départ c'est
l'enrichissement de la du contenu de la
croissance en emploi
euh sous réserve bien sûr
que ces allègements de cotisation
sociale ne se traduisent pas par des
hausses de salairire mais bien par des
un impact sur
l'emploi quand on
étudie les mécanismes au niveau
microéconomique omique au niveau des des
entreprises on peut s'intéresser à trois
mécanismes qui devrai être à l'œuvre euh
bah tout d'abord un effet de
substitution c'est-à-dire quand on
baisse le coût d'un facteur de
production relativement aux autres
facteurs de production et bien les
entreprises peuvent modifier leur choix
technologique leur choix
d'organisation et au en faveur de
l'emploi moins qualifié enfin l'emploi
au niveau des bas salaires puisque c'est
celui qui va voir son coût réduit en
allègement en allégeant les cotisations
sociales un autre effet qu'on appelle un
effet volume c'est bah la baisse du coût
du travail euh peut euh comment dire
être utilisé par les entreprises pour
baisser leur prix de vente euh et euh à
ce titre ben pouvoir stimuler leur vente
et leur production et et et donc là ça
fait un effet global donc de stimulation
de la production de de de l'entreprise
qui peut donc avoir un effet général sur
sur l'emploi et pas particulièrement sur
l'emploi qui bénéficie de ces
allègements de cotisation enfin un
dernier effet c'est l'effet
profitabilité c'est-à-dire l'entreprise
peut bénéfisser enfin profiter de la
baisse de son coût du travail euh de la
du coût de production pour
euh restaurer ses marges en tout cas
augmenter ses marges sans nécessairement
modifier son prix de vente et donc c'est
cette amélioration de profitabilité peut
être utilisée par les entreprises soit
pour restaurer sa situation financière
si elle étaé très dégradé soit pour
euhire accroître son investissement
enfin donc différentes différentes
directions
possibles alors en effet une des
questions très importantes quand on
s'intéresse au dispositif d'allègement
de cotisation social c'est la question
du ciblage euh d'ailleurs vous n'avez
pas manqué de la citer tout à l'heure
euh et quand on se pose la question du
ciblage ben on se pose en général trois
grandes questions d'abord c'est l'effet
sur la demande du travail euh est-ce que
le l'allègement de cotisation sociale va
agir de la même façon
euh suivant le type de le type de
ciblage suivant le le le type de
d'emploi et en fait toutes les études
économi convergent vers le fait que dire
ça dépend avant tout de l'élasticité de
la demande de travail au salaire et de
nombreuses études mettent en évidence le
fait que cette élasticité au salaire est
variable suivant le niveau de
qualification et donc le niveau de
salaire des salariés euh beaucoup de
mais ça pierre Cay va évidemment vous en
parler davantage euh beaucoup de travaux
ont ont mis en avant le fait que on
pouvait avoir une unasticité proche de
enfin unitaire au niveau des des des
emplois peu qualifiés et qu'elle elle
était beaucoup moins importante pour au
fur et à mesure qu'on montait dans
l'échelle des salaires
euh également C eff fait puisque bon
donc c'est c'est la logique du
fonctionnement du marché du travail
l'effet d'allègement joue aussi enfin
dépend aussi de l'élasticité de de
l'offre de travail au salaire et là
aussi celle-ci varie suivant le degré de
qualification des emplois dont on peut
parler un deuxième effet qui est
important à avoir en tête quand on se
pose la question du ciblage c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'effet d'assiette
c'est-à-dire B un budget donné enfin
enveloppe moyen budgétaire identifié qui
peuvent être consacrés à cette politique
d'allègement de cotisation sociale euh
l'efficacité de la mesure euh évidemment
sera d'autant plus importante qu'elle
est
euh elle sera d'autant plus forte que
euh l'effet euh est est estcalibré de
manière euh significative et donc euh
bah si on se concentre sur une une
population euh euh réduite évidemment on
pourra donc consacrer un budget plus
important avec donc une mesure qui
pourra euh comment dire être encore plus
euh sensible
euh si la politique d'allègement de
cotisation sociale couvre une très large
population de salariés à un budjet un
masse budgétaire donné forcément donc
les moyens seront plus limités pour
calibrer la l'importance de des
allègements de cotisation sociale enfin
un troisème effet qu'on qu'on mentionne
toujours qu'on à avoir en tête quand on
cherche réfléchir au ciblage des
allègements de cotisation sociale c'est
ce qu'on appelle l'effet de trappe à bas
salaire l'effet potentiel de trappe à
bas salaire donc je peux citer un
rapport très ancien mais qui dont les
réflexions restent peuvent toujours
rester d'actualité donc deson malinveau
qui est en
98 qui s'appelle les cotisations
sociales à la charge des employeurs et
qui donc ben poser la
question des effets comment dire
indésirabl potentiel hein dans ces
politiques d' de cotisation sociale dans
le sens où ça pourrait brider le
développement de carrière des
personnes également avoir un effet
négatif sur la productivité dans le sens
où il y aura peu d'incitation enfin il
pourit y avoir une espèce de phénomène
de blocage au niveau des basses salaires
puisque au-delà d'un certain seuil on ne
bénéficierait plus de cette politique
d'allègement
euh et donc à l'époque Edmond Malino
préconisait de du coup de bien veiller à
avoir un seuil de sortie qui soit pas
trop comment dire relativement large
pour se prémunir totalement de de cette
trappe potentielle trappe à bas salaire
euh donc j'eneviens très brièvement
juste au aux travaux qui ont été
conduits c'est juste un résumé très très
rapide euh des effets sur les des
allègements de cotisation sociale sur
l'emploi euh ces travaux en fait il
étaient pas très faciles à conduire une
première grande difficulté c'est qu'en
fait quand on on on essaie de se lancer
dans les travaux d'évaluation on a on a
toujours on est comment dire on est la
tâche est grandement facilitée quand on
peut disposer de ce qu'on appelle un
contrefactuel c'estàd une population
témoins une population qui n'a pas
bénéficié d'allègement de de cotisation
sociale et qui permettent de comparer
ben qu'est-ce qui se passe avec une un
allègement et qu'est-ce qui se passe
quand il n'y en a pas et là on se trouve
dans une situation de dispositifs
d'allègement généraux de cotisation
sociale donc qui couvre toute la
population
euh donc ben sur les bas salair en
l'occurrence et donc on n' pas
population témoin pour conduire ce ce
travail d'évaluation donc c'est une
première grande difficulté qui ben du
coup rendent difficiles les travaux
économétriques même si du coup la
plupart des économistes qui se se sont
consacrés à ces travaux d'évaluation ont
dû mobiliser des boîtes à outils
diverses et variés pour essayer
d'évaluer l'impact sur l'emploi la
deuxième autre difficulté importante
euh pour la deuxème vague de de
d'allègement de cotisation sociale à
partir de 98 c'est que là on se trouve
dans une comment dire euh un mixage de
mesures à partir de 98 donc ce n'était
pas simplement de d'enrichir la
croissance en emploi il y avait aussi
des tout un phénomènes qui sont
intervenus avec la réduction du temps de
travail et la convergence desesmic qui
donc a rendu plus complexes les travaux
d'évaluation puisque c'était très
difficile de pouvoir isoler les les
différents effets qui étaient à l'œuvre
alors bon en résumant donc la plupart
des travaux ont pu conduire à une
fourchette d'évaluation d'impact sur
l'emploi pour la première phase des
allègements de cotisation sociale donc
avant 98 à entre 200000 et 400000
emplois sauvés
ou sauvegarder ou créer
euh c'était encore ce qui a été cité
donc dans le rapport du du Conseil
d'analyse
économique donc je me souviens plus la
date exactement le 97 d'ailleurs donc
pierre Cu qui est un des
auteurs et la deuxième pour la deuxème
vague là où je vous ai dit que les
évaluations étaient encore plus
difficile enfin en prenant en compte
pardon la deuxème vague on arrive à un
total un ordre de grandeur qui qui est
généralement cité et qui est cité encore
dans les rapports du Conseil
d'orientation pour l'emploi à 800000
emplois donc créés ou sauvegardés
euh ces travaux d'évaluation bah donc
donne un chiffrage vous voyez que c'est
parfois une fourchette assez large he ça
montre un peu la difficulté de de
l'exercice euh il y a aussi comment dire
une préoccupation à avoir en tête qui
n'est pas toujours conduite B suivant
les outils qui sont mobilisés pour faire
ses travaux d'évaluation pour avoir un
une évaluation du bouclage budgétaire
global de de de ces de ces dispositifs
de cette politiques d'allègement de
cotisation sociale dans le sens où il
faut avoir aussi en tête enfin tenir
compte de du modalité de financement euh
de ces allègements de cotisation sociale
qui donc bah font partie aussi du coup
euh des effets
globaux enfin et pour terminer
euh je voudrais juste citer aussi un un
dernier travail du Conseil d'analyse
économique qui ne porte pas à proprement
parler sur les allègements de cotisation
sociale c'est une note qui a été publiée
en avril de l'année dernière euh sur la
dynamique des salaires en en temps de
crise et qui mettait en en avant euh euh
le constat d'un d'un écart qui se
creusait entre euh l'évolution de la
productivité et l'évolution euh la prod
productivité du travail pardon et
l'évolution des salaires donc B
globalement dans la période enfin depuis
2008 on se trouve avec une évolution de
productivité plate enfin complètement à
tonne et des des salaires qui continue
de de progresser et donc une
déconnexion assez forte en fait entre
ces deux ces
deux ces deux indicateurs économiques
hein donc avec un salaire net réel net
qui croit de l'ORD de 0,8 % chaque année
sur sur la période enfin pendant cette
période de crise et ce qui euh évolution
donc qui euh joue en défaveur de
l'emploi hein donc et en particulier
pour l'emploi peu qualifié et c'est
pourquoi sur la base de ce constate donc
je résume énormément mais donc la note
est accessible tous les travaux du CEAE
sont accessibles sur sur le site
internet euh parmi les recommandations
qui émergeaient euh il y avait celle de
des clisonner les les négociations
relatives aux rémunération à l'emploi et
conditions de travail euh de parce que
les les comment dire la
les la fixation du du salaire minimum
est un élément mais aussi les les
conventions collectives de branches
jouent beaucoup dans la dynamique
d'évolution salariale et peuvent bah du
coup jouer en en défaveur de l'emploi
euh pendant cette période donc donc
d'évolution très base de de la
productivité
et qui plusit dans une période de très
basse inflation et donc où il y a une
certaine rigidité évidemment à la baisse
régidité nominale dévolution nominale
des salaires et également était fait ben
parmi les recommandations celle de
d'adosser plus fortement le financement
de la protection sociale à une base
fiscale donc donc là c aller plutôt dans
le sens de de de d'intégrer les
allègements de cotisation sociale dans
les barèes pour que on soit plus dans le
comment dire dans un dispositif de
manière dérogatoire au droits commun
mais que le droit commun intègre en fait
euh comment dire une des barêmes
progressifs en fonction de l'évolution
des salaires bar de cotisation sociale
progressif en fonction des salaires
euh sur la base de des des constats
établis
que c'était favorable à à à l'emploi peu
qualifié
voilà merci Hélen pour cette
introduction je voulais aussi remercier
de me permettre d'intervenir sur ce
sujet préalablement j'aurais voulu
souligner
que une absence de situation de conflit
d'intérêt de ma part dans dans ce
domaine c'est un domaine dans lequel il
y a des dizaines voir des centaines de
milliards d'euros évidemment les
personnes qui s'expriment peuvent
s'exprimer au nom d'organisation
syndicale patronal céit pas mon cas je
m'exprime en tant que expert qui
travaille depuis 25 à peu près
maintenant j'ai du mal à le dire 25 ans
sur le sujet qui a été attiré par les
problèmes d'emploi parce que il y a 25
ans le chômage était élevé le chômage
est toujours élevé euh il ne baisse pas
en tendance euh et le sujet sur lequel
vous m'interrogez je pense extrêmement
important les enjeux en terme d'emploi
sont extrêmement importants je pense
pour répondre tout de suite à votre
question qu'il est essentiel de cibler
les baisses de charges sur les bass
salaires je vais tâcher de de vous en
convaincre dans cet exposé euh je pense
que nous avons économistes spécialistes
du sujet des idées assez claires que
nous sommes assez nombreux à avoir les
idées assez claires sur ce sujet je
vrais fait référence à un article qui a
été signé par 35 économistes du travail
dans le monde il y a à peu près un mois
tous spécialistes d'économie du travail
arti qui regroupe je dirais principement
l'ensemble des économies du
travail expert sur le sujet expert
académique en situation non non
conflictée si je puis dire euh donc
voilà donc pour pour pour
commencer première
remarque en France le salaire minimum
est élevé alors évidemment un salaire
minimum n'est jamais élevé en terme de
pouvoir d'achat c'est c'est mais
néanmoins lorsque l'on compare le
salaire minimum au salaire moyen si vous
avez des données au CDE qui vous seront
j'imagine représenté dans l'exposé
suivant qui compare le rapport entre le
salaire minimum et le salaire
moyen salaire brut brut he en
l'occurrence ici pour donc divers pays
vous VO que la France le rapport est de
48 % Sion compare au salairire médian le
rapport de 62 % en France c'est un des
des des niveaux les plus élevés au sein
des des des pays deocde comme vous
pouvez le voir sur ce graphique euh donc
le salaire est minimum est élevé de de
de ce point de vue lorsqu'on le compare
au salaire moyen au salaire médien il
est aussi élevé lorsqu'on compare en
coût du travail à dollar constant enfin
au T au taux de de change courant du
dollar ici pour pour l'année 2012 hein
vous voyez que la France se situe en 4e
position derrière l'Australie le
Luxembourg les Pays-Bas euh enfin au
même niveau hein que que que les
Pays-Bas ici euh et vous voyez que
l'essentiel est lié au salaire minimum
avec effectivement ici des taux de
cotisation qui sont réduits par rapport
au taux de
cotisation normal si je pe dire en
France qui est de l'ordre de de 45 de 45
points du du salaire brut euh alors euh
évidemment ici le le le la France il
faut bien comprendre sur ce graphique
que ce graphique sous-estime d'une
certaine manière la situation de la
France dans la mesure où en Australie au
Pays-Bas et aussi Luxembourg il y a un
salaire minimum plus bas sur les jeunes
pour les jeunes notamment au Pays-Bas
jusqu'à 23 ans il a un salaire minimum
qui monte de manière progressive pour
les jeunes idem en Australie je
reviendrai sur ce point tout à l'heure
mais lorsqu'on compare des niveaux de
coût du travail entre pays ou des
rapports au Sala médian ou au salaire
moyen il faut noter que ce qui
caractérise aussi la France c'est un
salaire minimum qui s'exerce de manière
extrêmement homogène il y a seulement
des dérogations pour les personnes de
moins de 18 ans alors que dans l'extrême
majorité des pays et bien il y a soit
des minimas différents pour les jeunes
voire par secteur donc la France se
caractérise par un salaire minimum élevé
et par un salaire minimum qui est très
homogène au sein de la population
euh regardons encore deux points sur
l'évolution du salaire minimum ici sur
ce graphique vous avez l'évolution du
salaire du du du salaire minimum réel en
en terme de parité de pouvoir d'achat
c'estàdire qu'il a le pouvoir d'achat
des personnes au salaire minimum alors
euh le graphique la France c'est euh si
vous regardez sur la droite c'est celle
qui termine le plus haut donc vous voyez
qu'en France il y a une tendance hein à
une augmentation du salaire du salaire
minimum donc suprimé ici en en dollar en
parité de pouvoir d'achat dollar 2011 et
vous voyez que depuis 1970 le salaire
minimum a été le pouvoir d'achat du
salaire minimum horaire a été multiplié
par 2 et demi en France c'est le pays
dans lequel il y a la plus forte
progression il y a une très forte
progression du salaire minimum en France
qui n'a pas cessé ces dernières années
vous voyez qui continue à croître en
terme de pouvoir d'ACh d'achat ici un
rythme néanmoins beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus restreint en ce qui concerne le
pouvoir d'achat du salaire minimum donc
depuis depuis
alors pour insister sur le fait que le
salaire minimum est en France à un
niveau élevé et finalement concerne une
grande partie de la population il est
intéressant de de regarder la le
pourcentage de personnes qui sont
rémunéré au niveau du salaire minimum
voyez si vous comparez avec des pays qui
ont des des tau des des salaires minimum
élevés comme j'ai montré tout à l'heure
comme l'Australie les Pays-Bas et bien
en France les taux pour l'ensemble de la
population de la pourcentage de salariés
qui sont couverts par le salaire minimum
est plus de deux fois élevé presque
pratiquement trois fois plus élevé enfin
deux fois et demi plus élevé disons plus
de deux fois et demi plus élevé et
lorsque l'on regarde les jeunes alors là
effectivement la situation est
extrêmement très différente puisque le
taux est pratiquement trois fois plus
élevé pour les jeunes comparé à
l'Australie alors que l'Australie
elle-même un salaire minimum plus élevé
en moyenne donc vous voyez ce qui
caractérise la France c'est vraiment le
fait que il y a un salaire minimum élevé
très homogène et donc qui couvre une
grande partie de la
population
alors il y a un fait femme aussi sur
lesquel j'ai pas insisté évidemment donc
le le salaire minimum touche beaucoup
plus les jeunes les femmes et les les
les personnes aussi en situation
d'entrée sur le marché du travail qui
sont beaucoup les les personnes
immigrées alors si l'on compare par
exemple la France et l'Allemagne vous
savez que l'Allemagne pour l'instant n'a
pas de salaire minimum un salaire min
minimum sera introduit en janvier 2015
si la loi actuellement en discussion en
Allemagne est votée et bien en Allemagne
nous avons fait un note pour le pour le
Conseil d'analyse économique sur la
situation des jeunes comparant la France
et l'Allemagne en Allemagne 60 % des
jeunes
qui ont un diplôme inférieur égal au bac
et qui sont en emploi ont un coût du
travail inférieur à celui du salaire
minimum français 60 % d'accord des
jeunes en Allemagne qui travaillent qui
sont hors apprentissage hein et qui ont
un diplôme inférieur égal auobac et bien
60 % de ces jeunes ont touch un un
salaire qui est qui correspond à coût du
travail plus faible que le coût du
travail au niveau du salaire minimum en
France cela pour signifier vraiment que
le le le le salaire minimum en France
euh a un impact potentiellement
important je vais revenir sur ce sur ce
point euh alors face à cette situation
comme l'a souligné Hélène Paris euh il y
a eu une une évolution des politiques
des politiques publiques euh notamment
euh par la mise en œuvre d'importantes
exonération de cotisation patronnale
ciblé sur les bas salaires euh à peu
près un point de PIB en ce qui concerne
les exonérations qu'on appelle les
exonérations Fillon dans le langage
commun euh à peu près un point de PIB
depuis janvier 2014 la réduction de liée
au au cice de 6 % de la masse salariale
brute en dessous de 2 6 m et demi
correspondrait environ à un point de PIB
et il y a 10 milliards supplémentaires
qui sont en discussion qui correspondent
à un demi- point de PIB et donc on est à
peu près à de 2 point et demi de PIB
pour ceses exonération de charge
concentré sur les sur sur les bas
salaires alors que que pensez de ces de
ces de ces exonérations de charges dans
la période récente je vourrais souligner
que dans la période récente le coût du
travail au niveau du salaire minimum a
continué à évoluer si vous regardez donc
hélè Paris a présenté des graphiques qui
représentaient l'évolution du du SMIC en
fait du rapport entre le SMIC et le
salaire et le salaire moyen
pour le pouvoir d'achat et pour le coût
du travail ici sur ce graphique vous
avez l'évolution du SMIC en euro
constant
d'accord et donc le SMIC réel c'est le
pouvoir d'achat et le la la la line
rouge c'est le coût réel et vous voyez
que en fait le coût du travail a
continué à augmenter au niveau du au
niveau des bas salaires tout simplement
parce que les cotisations sociales ont
augmenté he elles ont augmenté entre
2008 et maintenant elles ont augmenté de
4 points elles ont augmenté de 4 points
donc même il y a C des exonérations de
26 points et bien les les le coût du
travail est augmenté significativement
sur cette période au niveau du SMIC bien
que il y ait eu un seul coup de pouce un
petit coup de pouce sur la période de
2007 jusqu'à jusqu'à aujourd'hui 2014 et
donc ce qui explique que le pouvoir
d'achat du du SMIC a resté prtifement
stable sur cette période donc nous
sommes toujours dans une situation où en
fait le coût du travail continue à
augmenter à un rythme rapide au niveau
des bas salaires et d'ailleurs au niveau
de l'ensemble des salaires en France à
l'heure actuelle alors que pensez de
l'effet de ce cout du travail sur le sur
l'emploi aujourd'hui est-ce qu' exonérer
de qutis est-ce que baisser le coût du
travail ça conduit à à à créer des
emplois alors pour vous pour pour
essayer de vous de vous convaincre et
pour vous expliquer comment on se forge
une opinion sur ce point j'aurais voulu
vous présenter des travaux nous avons
mené sur ce sur ce sujet récemment avec
Stéphane carcillot et Thomas
lebarbanchon qui est d'un dispositif qui
nous a permis de bien évaluer l'effet
des baisses du du coût du travail au
niveau des bas salaires ce ce ce ce
travail est mise en perspective dans une
note qui vient d'être publiée pour
l'Institut Montaigne qui par l'Institut
Montaigne qui qui donc met en en
perspective ce ce ce travail en
comparant au travail aux autres travaux
point sur lequel je dirai de mots dans
quelques minutes alors quel est ce
dispositif ce dispositif a été mis en
place le 4 décembre 2008 euh où Nicolas
Sarkozi a annoncé que tout embauche en
dessous de un 6 fois SMIC serait exonéré
de cotisation patronal dans les
entreprises au moins de 10 salariés
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2009 euh alors
cette mesure qui était appelée zéro
charge plus précisément réduiser le coût
du travail à ce moment-là de pour les
petites entreprises de 12 % au niveau du
SMIC elle était 12 % du coût du travail
au niveau du SMIC et elle est
décroissante et elle s'annuent à 1,6
fois le SMIC d'accord donc elle est
calquée en fait sur les allègements de
de de cotisation sur les bas salaires
elle amplifie les allaigements de
cotisation sur les bas salairire pour
les entreprises de moins de de 10
salariés euh alors quel a été l'impact
de cette mesure pourquoi il est
intéressant d'étudier cette mesure et
bien il est intéressant d'étudier cette
mesure parce que justement elle nous
permet de disposer de ce que hlen Paris
a appelé tout à l'heure un groupe tmoins
c'est-à-dire que nous sommes dans un
contexte où pour des raisons budgétaires
il y avait à peu près à l'époque 1
milliard d'euros à à à consacrer à ce
dispositif dans leensble du plan qui
était prévu bien pour des raisons
budgétaires le gouvernement a décidé de
cibler ces baisses de charges sur un
groupe d'entreprises avec l'idée que les
entreprises petites employai plus
fréquemment des salariés peu qualifiés
et donc il aurait potentiellement des
effets plus importants sur l'emploi
peut-être pour ces petites entreprises
parce que elles emploient des salariés
peu qualifié alors donc on est dans un
contexte où les entreprises jusqu'à 10
salariés alors ce sont 10 salariés
équivalent en plein le décompte éta
effectué de telle sorte à ce que la
taille de l'entreprise ne puisse pas
être manipulée pour pouvoir bénéficier
du dispositif donc le dispositif a été
annoncé le 4 décembre 2008 le le le les
effectifs étaient calculés en en
équivalent temps plein sur la moyenne de
janvier 2008 et de novembre 2008 hein de
l'ensemble des moisallant de janvier à
novembre 2008 donc le jour où il y a eu
l'annonce qui était une surprise je je
le montrerai tout à l'heure et bien les
entreprises ne pouvaient plus manipuler
euh de facto leur taille euh elles
pouvaient mentir mais ne pas en tout cas
le manipuler en embauchant des salariés
supplémentaires pour pouvoir bénéficier
de de de de ou en en embauchant moins de
salariés pardon pour pouvoir ba
bénéficier de de la mesure euh alors euh
donc on
on l'avantage c'est qu'on va pouvoir on
peut comparer ici les entreprises de
moins de 10 salariés et de plus de 10
salariés avant et après la mesure donc
l'idée c'est que si on compare des
entreprises qui sont juste au-dessous de
10 salariés nous allons comparer SICI
dans dans dans dans positif enfin dans
la présentation centrale les entreprises
de 6 à 10 salariés avec les entreprises
de 10 à 14 salariés qui évoluent au
cours du temps avant la mesure de
manière parallèle et on va voir ce qui
se passe juste au moment de l'annonce de
la mesure pour faire ça nous avons des
données sur toutes les entreprises
françaises les DADS les déclarations
annuelles de données sociales plus un
fichier de P emploi qui nous permet de
connaître exactement de savoir
exactement quelle entreprise a touché
des l'aide zéro charge et pour quelle
embauche donc nous observons exactement
euh chaque entrée dans chaque entreprise
chaque jour à partir des DADS sur la
période allant de 2005 à 2009 euh donc
nous utilisons ce ces données donc qui
sont vraiment très précises et qui nous
permet d'avoir une vision très précise
de l'impact de la mesure alors euh donc
premier point cette mesure juste pour
pour vraiment vous vous convaincre que
cette mesure était une surprise en fait
un des co-auteurs de cette de cette de
cette étude Nicolas euh de Stéphane
carcillot était membre du cabinet de de
Christine Lagarde de Christine Lagarde à
ce moment-là il a donc participé en fait
à la mise en œuvre de cette mesure donc
il savait que cette mesure a été gardée
secrète selon la volonté du président à
l'époque et donc dans les fait on
s'aperçoit effectivement que ça a été
une véritable surprise il n'y a eu
aucune fuite sur ce sujet on le voit ici
quand on regarde le nombre de recherches
par exemple sous sous Google la la
grosse bosse et bien c'est à partir de
de de décembre 2008 euh et ce sont les
recherches associées à zéro charge à la
l'embauche donc il y a vraiment eu une
surprise donc les entreprises ont pas pu
ajuster leur manain d'œuvre avant avant
zéro charge la mise en place de zéro
charge par exemple en attendant
d'embaucher ce qui nous conduirait à
surestimer éventuellement l'effit zéro
charge donc de ce point de vue-là cet
aspect est important et je vrais
souligner que cet aspect est vraiment
unique à notre évaluation par rapport
aux autres évaluations qui ont été mené
en France puisque tous les dispositifs
qui sont qui ont été évalués étaient en
général connus et discutés depuis de
long mois et donc ces effets dont je
parle qui font que les entreprises
peuvent par exemple attendre pour
embaucher et bien on ne les a pas ici
dans cette dans dans dans dans cette
évaluation on n'est
pas il y aura des effets de Ben dans la
mesure où des entreprises qui embauchent
auraient de toute façon embaucher ils
vont toucher la ils vont toucher la la
la la prime la subvention mais on
pourrait nous dire qu'on trouve nous
allons voir nous allons trouver des
effets importants sur l'emploi on
pourrait penser qu'on peut trouver des
effets importants sur l'emploi parce que
les entreprises ont arrêté d'embaucher
parce qu'elles anticipaient queelles
vont pouvoir elles pourraient bénéficier
à partir d'une certaine date de la
mesure et donc ça ça pourrait amplifier
l'effet l'évaluation he la faussée la
biaisée
euh alors autre point
important oui là ce sont les simplement
les bas salaires ou c'est l'ensemble des
salaires non non là là c'est l'ensemble
des requêtes sur Google vous savez là ce
qu'on représente c'est l'ensemble des
requêtes c'est le nombre de requêtes
sous Google pour les gens qui vont
chercher zéro charge à laambuche parce
que l'idée c'est c'est c'est de se dire
que au moment où le où on annonce cette
mesure pour s'assurer que il y a un
effet de surprise on devrait s'il y a
s'il y a vraiment un effet surprise
s'apercevoir que tout d'un coup beaucoup
de personnes vont se poser la question
de savoir mais qu'est-ce que c'est ce
dispositif de zéro charge d' à
l'embauche et on vérifie bien que à
partir de début de décembre 2008 et bien
il y a apparemment un effet de surprise
hein c'est une manière c'est un indice
ce n'est pas une preuve c'est un indice
mais c'est voilà c'est c'est c'est un
indice alors aussi chose
importante évidemment la manière dont on
va dont on évalue cette mesure c'est que
on suit les entreprises de moins de 10
et plus de 10 salariés euh si on observe
une rupture de tendance ça peut être lié
au fait qu'il y a d'autres éléments qui
vont affecter cette ces tendance ces
tendan entre les entreprises de moins de
10 et plus de 10 salariés donc en fait
il faut bien avoir en tête le fait que
la seule mesure du paquet de relance qui
avait été mise en place à cette époque
là qui était spécifique qui était
spécifique aux petites entreprises
étaiit bien zéro charge il y avait pas
d'autres mesures qui pouvaient
influencer de manière différenciée euh
les entreprises de moins de 10 salariés
puis 10 salariés et il y a des petites
discontinuités réglementaires et
fiscales qui affectent l'emploi au seuil
de 10 notamment sur licensciement
économique euh mais euh qui n'affecte
pas en fait la distribution euh la
distribution des des des entreprises ici
on voit on a on a représenté euh sur
l'axe horizontal vous avez euh la taille
de l'entreprise calculée selon le
critère qui permet de bénéficier de zéro
charge sur l'axe horizontale donc la
barre verticale à 10 c'est à gauche de
la barre on est éligible à zé recharge à
droite on ne l'est pas et vous avez sur
l'axe verticale le nombre d'entreprises
s'il y avait s'il y avait un
d'importance changement entre les
entreprise au moins de 10 et plus 10
salariés en termees réglementairirees on
devra observer une bosse à 10 salariés
quelque chose que nserve pas du tout
donc il y a pas d'important effet de
seuil à 10 salariés et donc on peut
penser que les entreprises de moins de
10 salariés et plus de 10 salariés juste
au voisinage du nombre 10 ne sont pas
très différente hein alors on va le voir
tout de suite alors qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé sur zéro charge quelle a été
l'ampleur de la mesure la mesure a été
appréciée des petites entreprises et ici
vous avez sur ce graphique toujours sur
l'axe horizontale la la taille des
entreprises en fin 2008 les entreprises
à gauche donc sont éligibles les
entreprises à droite ne le sont pas les
petites croix bleues c'est ce qu'on
appelle le taux de recours c'est la
proportion d'entreprises qui ont recours
à zéro charge alors vous apercevez que
c'est relativement faible d'une certaine
manière c'est au maximum de 33 %
pourquoi et bien parce que des
entreprises une part important enfin non
négligeable entreprise à peu près 40 %
d'embauche non des salariés qui un
salaire au-dessus d'un sismique donc
évidemment ces entreprises ne vont pas
pouvoir bénéficier de zéro charge il y a
aussi des entreprises qui ont des salaes
en dessous d'un sismique mais qui aurait
des gains très faibles et donc qui
pensent que pour gagner quelques
dizaines d'euros et bien elle n'est pas
nécessaire en tout cas ça vaut pas le
coup de de de de de remplir euh la
demande pour pouvoir bénéficier de zér
charges alors pour pouvoir bénéficier de
zér charge ce n'était pas une une une
baisse automatique il fallait remplir un
formulaire d'une page très simple qui
était envoyé à P emploi service et donc
qui ensuite donner la légent de charge
sur une base trimestrielle d'accord donc
euh vous voyez que ce taux est il y a
des entreprises qui qui qui qui auraient
intérêt à le faire sur le papier mais
qui l'ont pas fait et euh vous avez
aussi euh vous vous apercevez que ce
qu'on appelle le taux d'attention ici
c'est la proportion d'embauche éligible
qui ont eu lieu et qui ont bénéficié de
la de la de de effectivement de la
mesure et il est au maximum de 50 % euh
alors pour une des raisons c'est que
pour certaines embauches il y avait
vraiment très peu de gains mais pour une
autre raison qui est pour toutes les
politiques publiques les taux de recours
sont faibles ils sont faibles pour le
RSA même pour les entreprises on
s'aperçoit que les taux de recours sont
malgré tout toujours relativement
faibles donc ce qui est frappant sur ce
graphique c'est que lorsqu'on met en
place des politiques de ce type là on
s'aperçoit qu'elles sont finalement
compliquées à mettre en œuvre on en a
une bonne illustration je pense avec ce
graphique dans la mesure où on
s'aperçoit que les entreprises autour de
8 ne9 salariés et bien commencent à
avoir un tau de recours qui chute
énormément pourquoi vraisemblablement
parce qu'il est compliqué de calculer
l'effectif c'est un un effectif
équivalent plein temps plein les
apprentis les emplois aid ne sont pas
comptés dans l'effectif euh les heures
supplémentaires
ne sont pas comptés dans le décompte
pour calculer l'équivalent temps plein
donc il est possible que beaucoup
d'entreprises aent pensé que et bien
elles étaient au-delà du seuil et ne
pouvaient pas bénéficier du du
dispositif ce qui peut expliquer le fait
qu'on a cette cette cette baisse vous
voyez qu'à droite il y a une petite
proportion de l'ORD de 3 % qui a
bénéficié de la de la mesure alors
qu'elle naurait pas dû alors ces erreurs
peuvent être aussi du au fait que les
déclarations annuelles de données
sociales sont mal R par les entreprises
il aussi ici de un peu d'erreur de
mesure bien que ce sont ce soit à priori
des des des données de très bonne
qualité donc c'est l'ensemble de ces de
ces faits qui explique qu'il y a pas une
rupture juste à 10 mais qu'il y a
quelque chose qui soit un peu plus flou
comme ça alors qu'est-ce comment on peut
dans dans ce contexte là comment on peut
évaluer ce qui se passe ben l'idée est
très simple comme je vous l'ai dit c'est
on va vérifier que avant 2009 avant 2009
il y avait une évolution parallèle de
l'emploi pour les entreprises de 6 à 10
salariés et pour les entreprises de 10 à
14 salariés on fait évidemment des des
test de robustesse pour faire varier
cette cette ces ces ces
euh ces ces intervalles euh mais
commençons à regarder ces intervalles
euh et euh donc et on regarde s'il y a
une rupture en 2009 alors vous avez sur
l'axe horizontal euh ici les années 2007
2006 2007 2008 vous avez euh ici sur le
trait bleu plein représente par exemple
en 2006 c'est le taux de croissance de
l'emploi des entreprises qui sont ont
des salariés de 6 donc j'ai mis de 6 à 9
c'est 9,99 salariés hein donc disons de
6 à à 9 ou 6 à 10 salariés tout dépend
la convention que l'on prend mais donc
c'est de 6 à 9, 9,99 salariés et donc
qui était de 02 % à peu près euh et donc
qui voyez qui décroit en 2007
2008 et ce que vous voyez c'est que
au-dessus vous avez les entreprises de
10 à 13,99 salariés en TR très pointillé
donc ce ce vous pouvez constater ici
c'est que jusqu'en 2008 il y a une
évolution parallèle et il y a une
rupture de tendance à partir en 2009 en
2009 quelque chose quelque chose change
il y a vraiment une rupture de tendance
donc comment on peut calculer ici
l'effet de zéro charge en acceptant le
fait que cette rupture de tendance est
bien lié à l'introduction de cette
mesure on a plusieurs manières de s'en
convaincre par la suite je vous donnerai
plus de détails sur ces points ben
comment comment on on calcule c'est très
simple on dit si finalement zéro charge
avait pas été mise en œuvre on aurait
observé av une évolution de l'emploi
dans les petites entreprises qui est
représenté par le trait vert ici enfin
qui est bleu en fin de compte qui est
bleu ou vert selon votre votre acuité
optique en
pointiller qui donc on aurait observé
ceci mais ce n'est pas ce qu'on a
observé on a observé une rupture qui est
présenté par le taux de plein et donc
l'impact de zéro charge est mesuré par
la différence entre ce que l'on observe
et ce que l'on aurait pu observer si il
n'y avait pas eu zéro charge et la
manière de reconstruire ce que l'on
aurait pu observer s'il n'avait pas eu
zéro charge et bien consiste ici à
supposer queil aurait continué à avoir
une évolution parallèle avec les
entreprises un peu plus grandes d'accord
et donc ici lorsqu'on fait ce ce calcul
ce que l'on observe c'est que ce qu'
l'on estime c'est que une baisse du coût
du travail de 1 % accroit l'emploi de 2
% dans un délai d'un an ici c'est le
taux de croissance de novembre à
novembre ici j'ai calculé sur ces
graphiques pardon on a calculé à chaque
fois le taux de croissance de novembre à
novembre le taux de croissance de
l'emploi de novembre à novemb novembre
en moyenne dans les entreprises de moins
de 10 salariés et des entreprises de
plus de 10 salariés donc ici on trouve
un un effet qui est fort qui est qui est
relativement fort plus un peu plus fort
que dans dans dans les études qui sont
habituellement consacré au sujet je vais
revenir sur ce point voire beaucoup plus
fort néanmoins dans notre contexte ce
chiffre est un minorant pourquoi c'est
un minorant de l'effet sur l'emploi
c'est un minorant de l'effet sur
l'emploi euh
dans la mesure
où les salaires ont pu augmenter
c'estàdire que si les il est possible
que les salaires a augmenté légèrement
et donc dans ces cas-là si les salaires
n'avaient pas augmenté on aurait trouvé
un effet plus grand on a ce sont des
choses que sur lesquelles nous
travaillons les salaires n'ont
vraisemblablement pas augmenté nous nous
Contin continu à travailler sur ces
sujets nous sommes sur des très bas
salaires qui sont à court terme très
influencés par le SMIC hein et donc
toutes les tous les recherches que nous
faisons pour l'instant sur ce point nous
confirment dans l'idée que les salaires
n'ont pas augmenté il y a aussi un
certain temps d'ajustement ici c'est
quelque chose qui est temporire les
entreprises ont besoin de temps pour
ajuster leur main d'œuvre et donc là on
regarde les choses au bout d'un an si
ces baisse de chargge était pérenne il
il est possible que et bien les
entreprises fassent croître leur
manœuvre de manière plus importante pour
atteindre une cible plus élevé
vraisemblablement ici les délais
d'ajustement de l'emploi sont pour
l'essentiel réalisés en France il y a
énormément d'embauches en CDD comme vous
le savez 90 % des embauches sont en CDD
euh et donc les délis d'ajustement
d'emploi de l'emploi sont de facto assez
rapides nous allons voir dans le
graphique précédent la subvention était
temporaire quand on sait qu'une
subvention est temporaire et bien
finalement on embauche souvent moins que
si c'est permanent donc aussi ça peut
sous-estimer lesffit et surtout un point
important c'est le fait que ici nous
comparons nous comparons des groupes qui
sont les entreprises de 6 à 10 salariés
de 10 à 14 salariés or vous voyez qu'une
faible proportion des entreprises de 6 à
10 salariés a été traité à bénéficier de
la mesure si vous voulez et une petite
proportion des entreprises de 10 à 14 ça
salari à bénéficier de la mesure donc si
on compare les entreprises par exemple
qui vont de 4 à 8 salariés euh les les
le groupe des entreprises petites qui
est ce qu'on appelle les groupes le
groupe traité he par à mesure qui a
bénéficié de la mesure aura bénéficié de
manière beaucoup plus intensive de la
mesure et si on élimine les entreprises
de 10 à 12 salariés dans notre groupe
témoin on éliminera des entreprises qui
ont bénéficié de la mesure lorsqu'on
fait cette comparaison on trouve un
effet pratiquement deux fois plus grand
on trouve un effet pratiquement deux
fois plus grand donc une baisse de coût
du travail réduit accroit l'emploi non
pas de de 2 % mais en fait de 3 et5i %
donc si vous voulez on pense que le
chiffre que l'on que l'on donne ici est
extrêmement prudent ce chiffre de de de
de de 2 % hein c'est ce qu'on appelle
une élasticité de de 2 et bien et et est
extrêmement prudent dans les fait je
suis assez persuadé que le chiffre est
dans les fait plus grand mais nous
préférons être être prudent sur le sujet
dans la mesure où nous donnons des un
chiffre qui est plus élevé celui qu'on
trouve habituel alors ce que l'on trouve
aussi c'est que l'effet sur l'emploi est
rapide l'effet sur l'emploi est rapide
ici nous avons calculé euh l'effet sur
l'emploi à partir du jusqu'au mois de
janvier février mars avril mai jusqu'en
novembre 2009 donc ce qu'on fait c'est
qu'on calcule le taux de croissance de
l'emploi non plus de novembre à novembre
comme précédemment mais de novembre à
janvier novembre à février et donc ici
ce sont ce que vous avez en trèspin en
très plein vous avez le taux de
croissance de de l'emploi de novembre à
donc janvier pour 2009 M1 2009 M4 ça
correspond à avril et les trait ointillé
ça représente l'intervalle de confiance
à 95 % c'estàd qu'il y a 95 % de chance
que l'on soit dans cette région comprise
entre les deux traits pointillés donc ce
qu'on voit c'est que à partir du mois
d'avril on trouve un effet significatif
positif sur l'emploi donc qu quelques
mois l'emploi s'ajuste l'emploi s'ajuste
rapidement et fortement lorsque l'on
baisse ici soudainement le coût du
travail et que les salaires ne s'ajuste
pas bien
évidemment alors quel est du coup le
coût par emploi créé de cette mesure bah
le coût par emploi créé de cette mesure
nous estimons que cette mesure a créé
environ 30000 emplois euh sur le champ
ici euh et euh les données dont nous
disposons indiquent que le budget pour
2009 a été de 360 millions d'euros donc
360 millions d'euros divisé par 30000 ça
fait 12000 emplois 12000 € par emploi
créé 12000 € par emploi créé alors 12000
€ vous allez me dire c'est cher
peut-être pourrait-on simplement donner
ces 12000 € aux personnes qui
travaillent au SMIC ça nous donnerait
finalement à peu près la même chose mais
évidemment c'est un coup brut il faut
tenir compte du coup net il faut tenir
compte du fait que lorsque quelqu'un
retrouve un emploi nous faisons
économies en terme de de finances
publiqu moins d'allocation chômage moins
de RMI RSA enfin RSA socle RSA pour les
personnes qui ont une durée du travail
très faible ou qui n'ont pas d'activité
euh moins d'allocation logement et des
cotisations sociales puisque les
salariés payent ici des cotisations
sociales au lordre de 20 % de leur
salaire donc euh l'estimation moyenne
retenue par Bery c'est que un le passage
de non emploi à l'emploi rapporte à peu
près 1000 € par mois en finan publi donc
le coût net est environ nul ici le coût
net est environ nul ici euh tel que nous
l'estimons donc un coup exanté qui est
important pas négligeable hein mais un
coup net qui est euh beaucoup plus
faible euh qui est au voisinage de zéro
ici et qui est bien sûr lié au fait que
nous avons des effets forts sur l'emploi
nous avons des effets forts sur
l'emploi alors ces résultats sont-ils
crédibles euh il faut se poser la
question puisqu'on trouve des résultats
plus élevés que les résultats qu' a don
dont dont tu as parlé Hélen Paris tout à
l'heure alors si on réfléchit à à
l'exercice qu'on a mené on peut se dire
finalement comparer des entreprises de
moins de 10 salariés et plus de 10
salariés au moment de l'entrée en
récession c'est un exercice dangereux et
sur lequel on peut avoir des doutes pour
pouvoir identifier l'effet de la baisse
de zérochge pourquoi parce que il est
possible que les entreprises réagissent
différemment selon leur taille lorsque
on rentre en récession vous savez qu'à
ce moment-là nous sommes juste rentrés
en récession donc pour voir si
effectivement notre exercice était était
était robuste à ce type de de
contreargument nous avons mené les deux
deux plusieurs exercices mais je vous en
indiquer deux premier exer 6 on a
comparé l'évolution des entreprises euh
au au au moment de l'entrere dans la
crise en 2009 exactement ce que nous
avons fait de 12 à 14 salariés et de 14
à 16 de et de pardon de 12 à 16 salariés
et de 16 à 20 salariés si les
entreprises de taille différentes avait
des évolutions différentes au moment de
l'entrée dans la crise en 2009 on
devrait observer une rupture de tendance
en 2009 les tendances sont exactement
parallèles je ne vous les ai pas
reportter ici elles sont sur le le
papier de recherche que je je vous en
verrai que je mets à votre disposition
euh autre autre on a aussi comparé
l'évolution de l'emploi des entreprises
de 4 à 7 salariés et de euh pardon de 1
à 4 salariés et de 4 à 7 salariés il y a
aussi pas de rupture de tendance donc la
seule rupture de tendance c'est pour les
entreprises entre 6 et 10 et 10 et 14 en
tout cas situé au des deux côtés du du
du seil de 10 salariés première chose
deuxième chose aussi on a étudié l'effet
sur l'emploi euh subventionné et non
subventionné au sein des entreprises des
petites entreprises au moins de 10
salariés en effet si la mesure un impact
sur l'emploi on doit s'attendre à ce qu'
a un impact sur l'emploi plus fort pour
les salariés situés en dessous de un
sismique que pour les salariés situé
au-dessus deun sismique d'accord donc en
faisant le même exercice en différence
de différence comme ça pour les salariés
qui sont pour les effectifs compris en
dessous de un sismique on trouve un
effet fort encore plus fort que ce nous
avons trouvé pour l'ensemble des
salariés des entreprise de moins de 10
et plus de 10 salariés et lorsque l'on
compare les salariés qui sont situés
au-dessus d'un sismique les effectifs
au-dessus d'un sismique on ne trouve
plus aucun effet donc ici aussi il
semble bien que l'effet soit juste ciblé
sur les effectifs qui ont bénéficié des
subventions et non pas sur l'ensemble
des effectifs d'accord donc ici aussi si
ça avait été une réponse une différence
de réponse et à la taille de
l'entreprise on aurait dû observer que
cette différence de réponse affecte
autant les salariés compris en dessous
de un sismique que les salariés compris
au-dessus de un Sismic donc pour toutes
ces raisons nous pensons que le fait que
l'économie rentre dans une récession et
que nous comparons des entreprises de
taille légèrement différentes n'affecte
pas la robustesse de nos résultats autre
point on pourrait penser et c'est tout à
fait légitime ce sont les effets
macroéconomiques dont parlait hlen Paris
tout à l'heure que les entreprises au
moins 10 salariés ont créé des emplois
certes c'est ce que nous montrons mais
au dépend des entreprises de plus de 10
salariés finalement on peut se dire les
entreprises de moins de 10 salariés ont
bénéficié de la subvention ont pris des
parts de marché aux entreprises de plus
de 10 salariés et c'est ce qui explique
votre effet au niveau macroéconomique il
n'est rien du tout nous avons regarder
cet effet en regardant si les
entreprises de plus de 10 salariés qui
étaient situé dans des bassins d'emploi
dans lesquels il y avait une plus grande
proportion d'entreprise de moins de 10
salariés qui étaient subventionné avait
un une croissance de l'emploi moins plus
faible évidemment si vous êtes situé
vous avez plus 10 salariés si vous êtes
situé dans un bassin d'emploi où il y a
beaucoup d'entreprises de moins de 10
salariés vous devrez être plus affecté
par les baisses de charge que dans un
bassin d'emploi où il y a peu
d'entreprises au moins de 10 salariés
donc nous avons découpé l'économie en en
348 zones d'emploi de de l'INC nous
avons calculé dans chaque zone d'emploi
la proportion d'embauche éligible
d'embauche subventionné d'entreprise de
moins de 10 salariés et voir si c'est si
ces proportions étaient expliquaient le
taux de croissance des entreprises de
plus de 10 salariés et nous trouvons
absolument aucun effet donc là aussi
nous trouvons pas du tout le fait que
les entreprises de 10 salariés a pu
croître au dépend des entreprises enfin
pardon les entreprises de moins de 10
salariés et puis croître au dépend des
entreprises de plus de 10 salariés donc
pour toutes ces raisons nous pensons que
ces résultats sont sont sont robustes
dans le sens où ils capturent vraiment
ils permettent d'évaluer d'identifier
effectivement l'effet de cette mesure
zéro charge sur l'emploi de manière
beaucoup plus convaincante que les les
évaluations précédentes qui se situaient
dans des contextes beaucoup plus vagues
et qui ne permettaient pas d'avoir un
groupe témoins très clairement identifié
tel que le fait notre notre notre notre
étude alors donc pour continuer deux
mots sur les comparaisons avec les
autres études dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure hélenne Paris il y a une étude
très connue de Bruno crpon et Rosen
despl qui a étudié l'effet des baisses
de chargees de 95
96 sur les bas salaires et la manière
dont ils essayaient d'identifier les
groupes témoins ils faisaient ceci en en
compar en comparant des entreprises qui
avaient une forte proportion de salariés
bénéficiant des baisses de charges avec
des entreprises qui avaient une
proportion plus faible de salariés
bénéficiant de baisse de charge vous
sentez que l'erci c'est beaucoup plus
flou que le nôtre beaucoup plus flou et
et donc il trouvait une élasticité plus
faible mais c'est normal parce qu'on
compare des entreprises qui ont
bénéficié un peu des des bases de
charges ave d'autres entreprises qui ont
moins bénéficié il est tout à fait
logique de trouver une élasticité une
sensibilité plus faible donc le le
chiffre qu'il trouve c'est que une une
baisse de 1 % du coût du travail et bien
accroit l'emploi de 0,8 %. il y a aussi
un article de de de Mathieu Bunel
Fabrice Gill et Yannick Lory qui étudie
l'effet des baisses de charges entre
2005 et 2002 et 2005 qui trouve une
vacité entre - 2 et - 01 une grande var
variation euh qui est aussi lié au fait
qu'ils sont obligés de faire des le même
type d'exercice que ce qu'on fait Bruno
crépon et Rosone desplace calculer les
coûts du travail des entreprises voir
quelles sont les entreprises qui
bénéficient plus ou moins des baisses de
charges et comparer ces différents
groupes qui sont exercices dans lesquels
il y a donc énormément d'erreurs de
mesure et en outre les baisses de
charges ici étaient complètement
anticipé puisque ces baisses de charges
qui étaient qui étit mise en œuvre par
par à ce moment à ce moment-là était
mise en uvre dans le cadre du vous savez
du rattrapage des un moment nous avons
vécu avec se SMIC lorsqu'il y a eu euh
la la convergence des SMI et des
différents du fait des 35 heurs euh
alors il y a une autre étude qui est
aussi qui trouve une élasticité proche
de la nôtre de Francis crramars et et
Thomas Philippon qui a une stratégie
différente qui compare la
probabilité de conserver l'emploi pour
des personnes qui qui sont rattrapées
par les augmentations du SMIC et pour
des personnes qui travaill juste
a-dessus du SMIC donc leur idée consiste
à suivre des personnes qui sont en
emploi à partir de l'enquête Emploi à
repérer les personnes qui euh sont juste
au-dessus du SMIC et ils regardent
ensuite lorsque ces personnes sont
rattrapées par les augmentations de Smic
ils comparent leur probabilité de
conserver leur emploi avec des personnes
qui ont un salaire juste au-dessus mais
qui ne sont pas rattrapé par les
augmentations de Smic et ce qu'il montre
c'est que les personnes qui sont
rattrapées par le les augmentation de
Smic ont une probabilité de perdre leur
emploi un 1 et5i % plus élevé que Cell
qui sont rattrapé par le SMIC donc ce
sont des chiffres qui sont pas très
éloignés du aôutre qui sont aussi d'une
certaine manière je pense beaucoup plus
entachés de de billet que les nôtres
parce que et bien les évolutions les
variations smiques qui regardaient
étaient aussi très largement anticipé et
donc à partir de là les effets sont
beaucoup plus difficiles à estimer alors
dernier dernier point sur sur sur tout
ça c'est ce que que je pense que ce que
nous pouvons constater ici c'est que les
baisses de charges sur les bas salaires
dans un contexte où a un chômage élevé
comme aujourd'hui en France ont en
France un effet potentiellement très
fort sur l'emploi l'effet que nous
trouvons est nettement plus élevé que
celui donc celui qui a été qui a été
trouvé par les autres études je suis
persuadé pour de bonnes raisons les
personnes aussi d'ailleurs vous pourrait
discuter avec ces personnes j'espère que
vous aurez l'occasion d'en parler sont
aussi évidemment nous avançons ensemble
sur ces sujets hein donc c'est pas ce
sont pas du tout des conflits
idéologique on cherche à avancer à
comprendre ce qui se passe donc ici nous
avons bénéficié de disons d'une bonne
expérience de de de bonnes données qui
nous ont permis d'évaluer de manière
plus fine euh cette
cette ce ce type de politique publique
et je crois qu'il y a convergence de ce
point de vue-là vers ce ce type de
résultat donc une forte élasticité ce
qui voudrait dire que les baisses de
charges tel que nous les connaissons à
l'heure actuelle le 20 milliard nous
permettrait de non pas de de conserver
entre 400 et 800000 mais ça pourrait du
double hein de de de niveau d'emploi
dans un contexte de chômage très élevé
alors pourquoi cibler sur les bas
salaires euh pourquoi finalement peut-on
s'attendre au fait pourquoi est-ce que
si si on étale ces baisses de charge on
pourrait avoir des effets plus faibles
pour deux raisons pour tout un ensemble
de raisons qu' qu'a rappelé Hélen Paris
mais sur lequel j'aimerais revenir en
quelques quelques minutes tout d'abord
premère raison essentielle qu'il faut
bien avoir en tête c'est le fait que
lorsqu'on bâche les charges il y a
toujours la possibilité que les salaire
que les les les salaires augmentent en
effet lorsqu'on baisse les charges et
bien ça revient à augmenter la non non
non non si si c'est pas le le point
auquel je voulais faire référence le
point auquel je voulais faire référence
c'est le fait que si les charges
patronnales baisse et bien il peut y
avoir ça revient c'est comme augmenter
la productivité si vous voulez votre
salarié coûte moins cher vous pouvez
augmenter son salaire si vous êtes un
employeur vous allez cherche patronnal
qui baisse ça vous donne un peu de un un
peu de marge de manœuvre pour augmenter
votre salarié et dans un contexte où sur
des segments du marché du travail le
chômage est faible pour attirer des
salariés l qu'il y a des difficultés
d'embauche et bien c'est un les
entreprises se font concurrence et ce
que nous montrent les travaux empiriques
c'est que lorsque le taux de chômage est
relativement faible et bien les baisses
de charges se traduisent par des
augmentations de salaire et n'ont
pratiquement pas d'effet sur l'emploi
c'est je fais référence ici un travail
de Jonathan grubber qui est professeur
mit qui a beaucoup travaillé sur ces
sujets c'est un article classique hein
qu'on enseigne en dans les cours
d'économie euh qui étudie l'effet d'une
très forte baisse des charges sur
l'ensemble des salair au Chili du fait
de la de la privatisation du système de
sécurité sociale donc les charges sur
les salaires ont au Chili baissé euh de
l'ordre de 20 % entre 1980 et 1986 mais
avec des taux des baisses différents
selon les secteurs d'activités euh des
différences très importantes P aller
jusqu'à 12 points de de différence entre
les secteurs donc ça ça lui permet
d'avoir des variations de construire des
contrefactuells et il s'est aperçu que
il y a eu aucun effet sur l'emploi et
uniquement des effets sur les salaires
c'est-àdire que ces baisses de charges
se sont traduites uniquement par des
augmentations de salaire pourquoi parce
que le taux de chômage était
relativement faible le marché du travail
était un peu tendu et donc et bien les
les entreprises se son font concurrence
pour les salariés et ce sont les
salaires qui qui ont augmenté donc en
France dans un contexte où les personnes
qualifiées qui sont au-delà de 25 SMIC
he je vous rappelle que en dessous de 25
SMIC nous avons à peu près 70 % des des
salariés travaillent en dessous de 25
SMIC donc 30 % des salariés qui qui qui
qui perçoivent un salaire supérieur à de
Smic et demi ont des taux de chômage
extrêmement faibles des taux de chômage
de lors de 5 % 4
% voire inférieur et donc évidemment ici
ce à quoi on peut s'attendre c'est le
fait que si les charges sont baissées
sur ces salaires et bien les salaires
vont augmenter comme l'a rappelé enen
Paris il y a sur l'ensemble des salaires
en France des une absence d'ajustement
des salaires à la baisse du fait du
ralentissement de la productivité c'est
lié à des problèmes structurels qui sont
liés à la manière dont fonctionnent les
négociations collectives faites qu'il y
a des extensions systématiques des
accords collectifs de branchees dans
lesquels les très grandes entreprises
jouent un rôle prédominant ce sont ces
ensembles l'ensemble de ces phénomènes
qui explique la rigidité des salaires la
baisse sur des hauts niveaux de salaire
et dans ce contexte là d'autant plus on
doit s'attendre à ce que si l'on baisse
les charges sur ces salaires élevé dans
ce contexte où les salariés ont
finalement un groupe de salariés on un
pouvoir de négociation relativement
élevé qui leur permet de ne pas baisser
leur salaire lorsqu'il y a une baisse de
la productivité et bien on doit
s'attendre à ce que les salaires
rattrapent très rapidement les enfin se
compens très rapidement les les les les
baisses de charges donc c'est
essentiellement pour cette raison que
nous pensons que les baisses de charges
sur des salaires relativement élevés
au-delà de un sismique se traduirait
essentiellement par des effets sur les
salaires très peu d'effets sur la
compétitivité donc en conclusion puisque
si les Sala augmente les effets sur la
compétitivité seront très faibles et
donc ça nous permet aussi de comprendre
le fait que
finalement les partenaires sociaux dans
leur ensemble sont plutôt pour un
étalement de des charges sur l'ensemble
des salaires puisque ça permet de
satisfaire l'ensemble des euh des
personnes qu'il représentent notamment
du côté des sal des employeurs
l'ensemble des entreprises et du côté
des salariés l'ensemble des salariés
sachant que bien évidemment les salariés
syndiqués sont en général plus âgés
travaillent dans les plus grandes
entreprises et bénéficieraient
relativement de ces accroissements euh
de de de de salairire de C accroissement
potentiel de salaire donc pour
l'ensemble de ces raisons il nous semble
qu'il est essentiel de cibler les
baisses de charges sur les bas salaires
quant à cet effet de trappe à bas
salaire nous navons pour l'instant pas
réussi à les mettre en évidence ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre sur ce phénomène de
trappe à bas salaire c'est le fait que
lorsqu'on baisse les charges ça augmente
les salaires le premier effet c'est
d'augmenter les salaires comme je vous
l'ai indiqué si vous êtes employeur si
vous avez moins de charge à payer chaque
salarié vous pouvez mieux le payer
d'accord évidemment en contre risque de
boucher voilà il un peu ça quand même
jou dans une entreprise c'estàdire que
c'est moins risqué euh sur une nouvelle
sur une nouvelle embloche c'est plus
facile de d'augmenter les salaires que
d'emboucher c'est parce y a quand même
la crainte à l'embauche il y a la
crainte oui mais la crainte à l'embauche
elle est elle n'est pas enfin elle a pas
grand chose à voir avec les baisse de
charge elle a pas grand chose la CRAT
l'embauche elle peut être liée à des
problèmes qui sont liés à la rupture du
contrat de travail des choses de ce type
là mais
urs plus vous baissez le CO travail et
MOS il aura C à l'embuche et plus vous
aurez la possibil durée ils sont pas
sûrs dans la durée oui mais ça joue
beaucoup ça quand même bien sûr mais ça
c'est très lié aux modalités de rupture
de contrat de travail ça c'est très lié
au modalité de rupture du contrat de
travail en France c'est pour cette
raison qu'en France il y a très forte
proportion d'emboch en CDD et une
proportion relativement faible CDDI sont
transformé en CDI mais si vous baissez
le coût du travail ce à quoi je faisais
référence c'est que si vous êtes mon
employeur si les charges que vous payez
sur mes salaires sont plus faibles bah
la première évidemment vous avez plus de
Marg de manœuvre pour mieux mieux me
donner partager cette baisse en fait de
de de de de cotisation donc le l'effet
le premier effet des baisses de charges
c'est d'augmenter les salaires en
revanche les baisses de charges baissent
les progressions salariales pourquoi
parce que les baisses de charges elles
sont maximales au niveau du SMIC et
ensuite elles décroissent et donc des
baisses de charges plus généreuses ça
augment la progressivité de la taxation
plus vous augmentez le salaire et moins
vous bénéficiez de baisse de chargege à
profil constant d'accord et donc ce dont
on s'aperçoit c'est que les baisses de
charges doivent augmenter l'ensemble des
salaires mais elles réduisent la
progression salariale donc donc quand on
parle de de voilà et cet effet de de
réduction des progressions salariales
nous ne sommes pas arrivés les études ne
sont pas arriv à le mettre en évidence
pour l'instant même dans un contexte où
les baisses de charges étaient ciblé sur
des salaires une une une palette de
salaire beaucoup plus basse de 1 à 1 TR
SMIC puisque les premiers allègements
qui avaient été mis en place par
Monsieur Jupé étaient situé entre 1 et
un trmic à partir de 1993 me semble-t-il
donc ici tout milite pour baisser les
charges sur les bas salaires et lesvanta
de 1 à un sismique hein entre 1 et un
sismique il a à peu près la moitié des
salariés qui travaillent et lui-même
déjà très large il est possible qu'
enfin on pourrait gagner plus en emploi
entr et dernier point pour pour pour
conclure
euh dernier point pour conclure je
conclus mais mais je vous en prie
euh dans dans le débat sur ce sujet on
entend souvent dire que choisir de
réduire les charges sur les bas salaires
ça revient à à à se se se spécialiser
sur des créneaux à faible faible valeur
ajoutée sur les emplois très peu
qualifié nous sommes dans un contexte où
le taux de chômage sur les les personnes
les les peu qualifié est énorme 15 le
taux de chômage des jeunes est à 25 % il
regroupe essentiellement des des des
jeunes peu qualifiés le meilleur moyen
de donner on sait que le meilleur moyen
de donner des qualifications aux jeunes
c'est de les faire travailler c'est de
les faire travailler de les mettre à
l'emploi d'apprendre en travaillant
toute les études empiriques montrent que
le meilleur moyen de disposer d'un
emploi après une certaine période c'est
d'avoir travaillé c'est souvent enfin
statistiquement c'est plus efficace que
les programmes de formation pur hors
hors emploi donc le meilleur moyen
d'avoir de monter en gamme d'avoir des
personnes qui accumulent des compétences
c'est de commencer par faire rentrer ces
personnes sur des emplois dans sur des
vrais emplois et donc de ce point de
vue-là on a énormément de marge de
manœuvre pour manipuler enfin pour faire
baisser le coût du travail et ce sont
sur ces segments qu'il faut qu'il faut
jouer voilà je vous remercie merci pour
votre attention nous vous remercions
aussi de de ce long exposé liminire mais
qui a permis quand même de de balayer
sujet pour disons une une réunion
introductive ça a permis de bien voir
les choses mais sans plus tarder je vais
donc passer la par un certain nombre de
de questions vous y avez déjà un peu
répondu mais bon d'abord on est sur de
la macroéconomie donc c'est toujours
très compliqué de suivre et et d'être
complètement convaincu évidemment ce
sont des études
donc
elles ont
leur leur légitimité mais en même temps
parfois on a l'impression que ça
correspond pas tout à fait à la
réalité la macroéconomie mais bon ça
c'est un sentiment que j'ai donc ça veut
dire que c'est c'est très important de
creuser vous l'avez fait d'ailleurs et
l'exemple que vous nous démontrez à
travers cette ce groupe témoin euh est
assez intéressant mais c'est un groupe
témoin sur des très petites entreprises
qui a un domaine et et un domaine
économique très particulier avec ses ses
règles et qui ne peut pas forcément je
pense appliquer à tous les domaines
économiques mais on va continuer à
creuser ces sujets pour pouvoir
justement le vérifier ceci dit euh euh
globalement il y a quand même euh un
certain nombre de de doute aujourd'hui
qui s'exprime sur l'efficacité des
allègements de cotisation sociale sur
l'empoil euh dernièreend date étant la
Cour des comptes qui nous a un petit peu
abreuvé de de son scepticisme alors je
vais vous poser des questions mais pour
revenir sur des sujets que vous vous
avez déjà apporté des réponses
euh en cinq cinq questions hein quel
outil pour mesurer les effets sur
l'emploi des exonérations de cotisation
social patronale vous avez expliqué un
peu hein et peut-on considérer que les
exonérations de cotisation sociale
existantes sont un instrument efficace
de lutte contre le chômage cont tenu de
leur coût mais vous avez déjà en partie
répondu
parmi les instruments de la lutte contre
le chaumage le coût du travail vous
semble-t-il la question prioritaire là
aussi on a entendu un peu votre opinion
dans cette hypothèse quel ciblage
privilégié donc les bas salaires après
les PME les secteurs exposés à la
concurrence internationale on élargit le
spectre là de du
ciblage dans les débats actuel sur le
pacte de
responsabilité la politique de
compétitivité des entreprises est-elle
une politique
de l'emploi sachant que la restauration
des marches des entreprises ne conduit
pas nécessairement à des embauches et
enfin ce qui amène donc à ma dernière
question quels sont les mécanismes de
contrepartie en terme de création
d'emploi qui pourrait être
envisagé alors simplement en en vous
demandant de répondre quand même assez
brièvement mais exhausivement bien sûr
mais assez brièvement de façon à ce que
les autres questions puissent être
posées avant 17h euh j'en ajouterai deux
simplement très brièvement euh en même
temps
euh il semble que votre choix se porte
sur une réduction des charges sur les
bas salaires tel que vous nous l'avez
exposé euh ù situez-vous le niveau euh
hein j'ai pas exactement identifié si
c'était entre 16 et 25 j'ai pas
exactement vu et
euh vous nous avez indiqué que pour je
veux dire les réductions de charge zéro
charge Sarkozy donc vous estimiez que ça
ne coûtait rien hein puisque voilà et
est-ce que si vous deviez généraliser ça
sur les 20 milliards existants est-ce
que vous êtes en mesure de donner une
une évaluation je sais bien que vous
avez pas pu l'identifié mais quel quel
est le le coût pour la collectivité
puisque à l'heure actuelle on on se dit
il y a 20 milliards là qui sont là
est-ce que vraiment il ne coûte rien ou
est-ce qu'il coûte un
peuok bon je vous remercie pour euh pour
toutes ces questions j'ai j'ai j'ai
répondu déjà explicitement ou
implicitement à à certaines d'entre
elles donc sur l'outil d'évalu sur
l'outil quel outil pour évaluer
l'évaluation a besoin d'un contrefactuel
donc l'évaluation a besoin d'un
contrefactuel et a besoin d'être
indépendante et prend du temps donc
mener c'est c'est c'est c'est essentiel
c'est essentiel sur le sujet
euh donc ça veut dire qu'il faut mettre
en place si possible des dispositifs qui
soient expérimentaux faut pas hésiter à
mettre en place des dispositifs qui
soient expérimentaux pour pouvoir
comprendre ce qui se passe c'est
essentiel vous savez que ça fait 30 ans
qu'on met en place des politiques
d'emploi on commence cette cette cette
culture de l'évaluation commence à se
développer en France de plus en plus de
chercheurs la mettre en œuvre je pense
c'est une bonne chose mais nous avons
encore énormément à apprendre et c'est
essentiel pour éclairer le le débat
public avec des méthodes simples et
transparentes les méthodes simples et
transparentes sont des méthodes avec
contrefactuel les méthodes trop
sophistiquées sont incompréhensibles par
le grand public comme par finalement les
chercheurs le plus souvent
euh 2uxème point sur le ciblage euh il
faut cibler vous l'avez compris euh
enfin selon nous sur les bas salaires
euh je je dis selon nous parce que c'est
nous économistes du travail en France
euh enfin j'ai fait référence à cette
cet article à signé du monde qui n'était
pas un article à mon initiative mais que
que j'ai signé
euh qui qui montre bien qu'il y a
vraiment un consensus très fort de la
part des de la part des des personnes
qui travaillent sur ce sujet euh qui qui
mènent des évaluations un Sismic un
Sismic c'est S c'est sûrement élevé la
moitié des salariés ins sismique les
taux de chômage et les personnes qui
potentiellement peuvent avoir un salaire
de ins sismique ont des taux de chômage
relativement faible he 7 6 % 5 %
euh donc il faut pas hésiter à cibler je
pense il faut pas hésiter à CIBL à
cibler jusqu'à 1 peut-être bon c'est
difficile de savoir ce qui est
exactement mais mais en tout cas 1 c'est
déjà élevé 1 6 c'est déjà élevé donc 2
5 2 5 c'est c'est c'est c'est beaucoup
c'est c'est c'est très élevé euh
euh donc
votre
alors PME commerce
international je crois je crois
qu'il les PME leurs caractéristiques
dans sa dimension c'est d'employer
beaucoup de personnel peu qualifié
d'avoir des plus bas salaires que les
grandes entreprises donc c'est pour ça
c'est si vous voulez par rapport
l'exercice que nous avons mené vous
dites ce sont les petites entreprises
mais c'est vraiment la différence
essentielle ce que nous savons ce que
nous apprend la littérature économique
c'est que
euh l'emploi est plus sensible pour les
salariés peu qualifiés pour les salaires
qualifiés les salariés qualifiés au coup
du travail en revanche selon l'état
l'entreprise une fois qu'on tient compte
du fait que la main d'œuvre est
différente du fait de sa qualification
son niveau de
salaire il y a pas on a aucune évidence
qui montrerait que l'emploi réagit
différemment selon dans les grandes et
petites entreprises autrement que via la
la la qualité de la mod si vous voulez
donc de ce point de vue-là cibler sur
les PME je pense pas que ce soit
forcément une bonne idée ce sur quoi il
faut cibler c'est c'est effectivement
c'est sur sur les bas salaires pour deux
raisons un parce que c'est plus sensible
et deux parce que au niveau des bas
salaires les salaires sont fixés par le
SMIC donc les salaires ne vont pas
augmenter le taux de chômage élevé les
salaires ne vont pas augmenter et c'est
là qu'on a donc les effets maxima euh
pas forcément l'un ou l'autre ça peut
être les deux facteurs
ensemble vous avez raison mais comme
comme je voulais comme je voulais
indiquer rien n'indique que l'emploi peu
qualifié ne soit pas sensible à son coût
dans les grandes entreprises hein son
les entreprises emploi très peu
d'emplois d'emplois peu qualifiés quand
quand quand on subventionne les salariés
à bas salaire les bas salaires on
subventionne de facto beaucoup les
petites entreprises hein voilà mais
ensuite cibler selon le seil
d'entreprise plus plus une mesure est
simple meilleur estl en général hein
c'est un point qu'il faut qu' faut pas
oublier les mises en œuvre des mesures
compliquées sont en général très
problématiques réduisent les taux de les
taux de recours
euh posent des problèm de définition des
seuils et donc sont de de de mon point
de vue à éviter donc ce qui concerne la
compétitivité le sujet de la
compétitivité est est assez est assez
différent le sujet de la compétitivité
les entreprises qui exportent payent des
salaires élevés au-delà de de ce miic et
demi des donc donc le salaire moyen des
entreprises qui exportent est très élevé
euh il y a un sujet pe-re sur la
formation des salaires qui est un sujet
différent euh comme je l'ai indiqué il y
a des sujets sur la formation
l'articulation de la recherche de la
formation des sujets aussi
réglementaires euh des sujets sur la
taxation de l'entreprise non pas du coût
du travail sur le coût du travail mais
sur des impôts locaux li à taxation
l'entreprise donc ce sont d'autres
sujets mais
euh la compétitivité est un sujet qui
est qui est différent simplement juste
une petite parenthèse pour prolonger ma
question est-ce qu'il y aura pas un
problème de conciliation entre le cuuce
qui va jusqu'à 25 et euh les mesures
éventuelles qu'on
oui oui le le cice est euh le cice est
sûrement trop trop trop enfin le cice
est trop étalé
euh donc si vous voulez le le fait que
le CCE soit assis sur la masse salariale
implique qu'il soit trop étalé on
pourrait penser d'utiliser une partie du
cice pour financer d'autres choses euh
qui soient directement lié à la
compétitivité mais de que c'est assis
sur les salaires et bien euh il faut la
logique économique consiste à le cibler
vers le bas quit à prendre quelques
milliards pour alléger d'autres types de
taxes mais en tout cas sur les salaires
la logique consiste à vraiment les
cibler sur les bas salaires le risque
que les salaires augmentent est
extrêmement important N'oubliez enfin
ayez ça en tête c'est vraiment
extrêmement important il est vraiment
extrêmement important toutes les études
empiriques empiriques le
montrent
je pense avoir répondu à l'ensemble
question on va laisser la parole à nos
collègues et je sais si on a un peu de
temps je je vous rappellerai ce que vous
avez oublié monsieur desessar fait une
vous posz une question oui Monsieur
Merci monsieur le Président j'aurais une
question toute naïve et certainement que
vous allez pouvoir m'y répondre et
m'aider à comprendre je crois qu'on peut
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord qu'on
parle de par exemple en 2013 de 20
milliards d'euros 20,5 milliards d'euros
d'All de charge j'ai cru voir dans un
une photo un moment que cela on pouvait
penser que ça avait créer entre 200000
et 400000 emplois j'ai cru voir beaucoup
plus 000 comment 800000 ah c'est 800000
d'accord parce que j'avais fait un
calcul les 200 les 200 à 400 ce sont les
c'est la première
vague ah d'accord donc je me suis trompé
parce que je vais prendre mon calcul sur
qu' fait la masse de 30 non en faisant
la masse en la faisant la masse d'accord
oui ça augmente le taux d'emploi général
parant parce que j'avais fait mon calcul
sur 400000 donc vous allez comprendre
mon calcul est très simple 20,5
milliards d'euros pour 400000 emplois
donc 20,5 m 10^ 9/ par 4 par 10^ 5 ce
qui fait 20,5 par 10^ 4/ 4 on arrive par
an par emplo créé si c'est 400000 à
51250 € divisé par 12 pour avoir un
salaire mensuel et les charges
mensuelles nous étions à
4269 € charges et salaire par mois par
emploi créé pour 400000 donc je disais
pourquoi se fatiguer à faire une
exonération de charg puisqu'on pouvait
dire on fait 200000 aide soignante
200000 aidees à domicile et puis on a
400000 € parce qu'avc 4 9 € par mois on
a les moyens de créer 400000 emplois
maintenant vous parlez de 800000 donc je
vais diviser par 2 on est à 2130 € par
mois là c'est plus difficile d'avoir un
temps plein je le conçois donc merci de
la précision des 800000 hein mais malgré
tout le chiffre de 230 € est quand même
intéressant non mais donc pour que les
choses soient bien claires je vais je
vais demander à à les deux autres
collègues qui veulent intervenir aussi
de le faire comme ça je on sera sûr que
tout le monde aura plus poser ses
questions alors tout d'abord monsieur
Dominati et ensuite monsieur dodini oui
moi je souhaiterais d'abord rebondir sur
une observation de Madame la rapporteur
c'est-à-dire que est-ce que dans vos
calculs économiques parce qu'on on voit
qu'ils sont évidemment extrêmement
fondés poussé on tient compte de la
flexibilité vous n'en tenez absolument
pas compte parce que lorsqu'on parle du
coup coût du travail est-ce que dans une
comparaison internationale vous pouvez
nous dire si c'est le coût théorique du
travail ou le coût réel du travail
lorsque une entreprise est en une
difficulté comme elle n'a pas la
flexibilité effectivement sur l'emploi
ce qui est je pense un frein à
l'embauche et bien dans ces conditions
il faudrait pouvoir rajouter ce coût lié
à la flexibilité dans vos calculs à
moins que vous les ayez pris en compte
donc c'est je je dirais une demande de
précision par rapport je dirais aux
organismes internationaux deuxièmement
j'aimerais que vous nous donniez un
sentiment alors là qui n'est pas fondé
par l'économie mais encore que vous
deviez vous vous avez certainement des
pistes c'est euh le travail au noir tout
simplement c'est-à-dire à partir de quel
seuil euh on voit se développer dans un
certain nombre de pays d'économie
européenne et et du sud de l'Europe le
travail au noir dans la presse
actuellement on voit pas mal d'articles
en France concernant la la résurgence de
ce type d'activité dans notre pays et ça
m' cite à vous donner un point de vue
peut-être sur ce qui avait été les
emplois à domicile avec les exagérations
est-ce que c'est un effet bénéfique pas
bénéfique de supprimer ces exagérations
voilà les trois les les trois précisions
que j'aurais aimé
avoir monsieur oui merci monsieur le
Président la démonstration était très
convaincante et intéressante à suivre je
voudrais revenir sur la notion emploi et
compétitivité pour peut-être que vous
alliez plus loin dans l'explication
alors emploi je comprends bien c'est lié
tout simplement au taux de chômage donc
tout le monde saisit compétitivité c'est
permettre à nos entreprises d'exporter
mais aussi peut-être d'être en plus
compétitive à l'intérieur de notre pays
par rapport à des entreprises
extérieures qui exportent en France donc
des produits que nous importons alors
jusqu'à quel point ces deux objectifs
emploi et compétitivité se
recouvrent-ils à quel moment il y a-t-il
divergence éventuellement sinon
opposition mais moins divergence entre
les les deux alors le cice n'est-il pas
un dispositif qui répond spécifiquement
à la compétitivité puisque les études
semblent-il récentes pour l'année 2013
indique que le coût du travail a moins
augmenté en France qu'en Allemagne je
crois que j'avis en tête de points ou
quelque chose voisin de ceci alors que
les salaires ont augmenté néanmoins en
France comme en Allemagne donc ce serait
bien un effet compétitivité du cice
alors si éventuellement il y a sur ce
point précis erreur dans mon
raisonnement merci de me le
montrer je vous en prie sachant que on
va déborder un petit
peu très bien sur les 400 800 et autres
vous avez enfin vous avez tout à fait
raison ce chiffre de 400000 est calculé
avec une élasticité de 0,5 en fait
c'estàd que si on baisse le côt du
travail de 1 % l'emploi va augmenter de
0,5 %. nous on trouve
de de 0,5 il provient d'un livre qui a
été publé en 1993 par qui un livre sur
la demande de travail qui est une sorte
de classique qui provient de nombreuses
études qui une sorte de chiffre moyen
qu'utilisent beaucoup les
macroéconomistes pour calibrer les
modèles qui concerne l'ensemble en fait
de la de la de des salariés alors le
chiffre de 1 donc on passe de 400 à 800
on fait passer de 05 à 1 pourquoi he
parce que dans ce livre on dit aussi
finalement les salariés moins qualifiés
c'est plutôt de l'ORD de 1 donc
euh voilà donc on prend un parce qu'ussi
les premières études que je vous ai
indiqué notamment crépond desplace
trouvait uneité 0,8 donc 1 08 c'est
assez proche il faut voir que tous ces
calculs sont vraiment faits hein c'est
des calculs de coin de table même quand
ce sont des gros modèles on rentre des
des paramètres voilà euh nous ce que
nous trouvons et comme j'ai essayé de
vous en convaincre c'est que cette
élasticité est plus grande et nous
sommes pas les seuls encore quand on
j'essaie d'insister sur le fait que les
les les les études les plus
convaincantes sur le sujet qui
identifient le mieux l'effet des baisses
de charg ou des augmentation que du
travail trouve des élacités plus grandes
en France elle trouvve des élités plus
grandes de l'ORD de 1 et demi 2 voire je
pense sur le fond plus grand donc c'est
pour ça qu'on trouve ce chiffre qui est
beaucoup plus petit donc nous on est pas
à 800000 on est au double de 800000
d'accord
donc voilà voilà on est à
double voilà
voilàà et et donc voilà bon la réponse
est clair ensuite je vous laisse vous
forger votre votre opinion voilà vous
avez pu suivre les premières auditions
de la mission commune d'information de
la réalité de l'impact sur l'emploi des
exonérations sociales accordées aux
entreprises tout de suite la suite de
nos programmes sur public
sénna